[Music]
foreign
she says when you lift weight you
demonstrate
eight
[Laughter]
yep you're practically Hitler if you're
like if you like keeping
Fiddler
they just wanted to say Hitler
in an interview with Time Magazine
author Natalia mailman pretzel or uh
details how her upcoming book explores
the ugly history of exercise
I'm getting Dumber reading this and no
it's not about Greg's secret years as a
Zumba instructor
[Laughter]
ugh even when he's away his creepiness
is always with us
the article if that's what we're calling
it is called the white supremacist
origins of exercise and six other
surprising facts about the history of
physical fitness I think we're already
surprised
during the interview Natalia argues that
in the early 20th century people pushed
the idea of Fitness so that women could
stay strong to have babies white babies
I can't
what
roll that back
she's right women but why wouldn't you
say white women I'm confused white women
can stay strong to have white babies
[Laughter]
oh my blackness is so upset right now
all right she also frames she also
frames the history of exercises totally
part of the white supremacy project
yeah that really worked out well with
the NFL and the NBA track and field
boxing and most competitive Sports
mission accomplished supremacist
oh so I guess I should stop lifting
weights because some white people wanted
to exercise their racist reasons a long
time ago but the most surprising fact is
stuff like this actually got published
but then again so did this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um you're white uh
and you have children yes how many times
have you walked in the room and told the
old lady to get on the dumbbell so she
can get those arms ready to pull out
those babies
well uh somebody online I think it was
zooby he commented that this was almost
a parody this article but the thing is
of all the things that leftists have
written it's not that far from I mean
obviously exercising is not racist but
it is kind of elitist I mean I don't
know any coal miners who got a Peloton
you know what I mean like
if you work with your hands if you're a
fruit picker if you work on roads if you
do real work you don't exercise because
you're working really hard yeah you're
jacked yes because you work in a coal
mine and you would beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody on a Peloton
something is different
I'm colorblind but I feel like
something's off I gotta blow out during
the break all right
Katie okay if if exercise this is what
drives me crazy because
the idea of being racist is you don't
accept or allow another group incorrect
is that do we all agree like that's the
point like that's so wouldn't you like
ban everyone else from exercising if it
was race oh yeah gym class would just be
all Tom and I'd have to wait outside no
so these kinds of articles are not
written for uh Republicans or minorities
even who they think shouldn't be
exercising because it means they're
engaging in white supremacy they're
written for woke white women who are
very guilted into doing things that are
virtue signaling so this is written for
them and if you've ever been on Tick
Tock or you listen to them screaming
into their phone this close and you
watch them wear their Lululemon pants as
they scream at black cops about how
they're part of the problem they're the
kind of people who should be in the gym
and so they're trying to keep white woke
women out of the gym to keep them
looking the same what they do because it
makes them look really bad when they're
screaming into the phone way too close
to their face cat Katie's point is this
just an excuse for someone who doesn't
want to work out and I can't work out
it's racist if you don't want to work
out just say that yeah
there's you there's PL you know you can
have all have a whole career off of not
working out too now like there's fat
fluencers you can totally be one of
those I'm sorry one more time
have you ever been on Instagram they're
all like I'm super fat and I'm really
happy
said no one no but say a lot of people I
feel like if you have to talk about it
yeah how happy you are that's like the
couples who's their whole Instagram is
like pictures of them like every picture
it's like oh man the smiles like this
hate each other like you're only ever
smiling when the camera is on you and
other than that you're screaming so it's
kind of like that you don't want to work
out you don't have to work out do we
have to study everything do we have to
study exercise like in terms of like the
origins of exercise it's exercises
exercise yeah I think exercise started
when you didn't want to get eaten by
something right so you ran away in
practice that was my problem problem
with this is the journalism here was
actually very flimsy and she could have
pushed it back much much further to
different societies you know and Beyond
anatomically modern humans you know what
were what were our ancestor hominids
doing for millions of years they were
running to save themselves so yes we are
genetically programmed to be fitter so
we survive but you know this is just
click bait because people are lazy and
they know if they do actual journalism
with real facts no one's going to click
on it because it's actually kind of
boring so they just make things up like
this in the cat's point is an excuse to
not do something you don't like so I
mean vacuuming is racist yeah it is
washing dishes it is it has its roots so
is laundry white supremacy I think the
Nazis invented polishing laundry and
polishing stainless steel so we should
not be doing any of that
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else